c'est une longue artère qui traverse
saint Benoît de la Nationale 2 à l'océan
dans la rue Auguste de Villèle la
végétation ne protège guère les cités
voisines du va-et-vient cessant des
autos c'est tout au bout de la rue que
l'on retrouve le calme et les ruines
d'un passé révolu la mémoire d'Auguste
de Villèle est-elle elle aussi en ruine
parce que vous savez qui était Auguste
de Villèle non pas du tout juste de nous
comme ça mais sans sans vraiment savoir
question
et alors c'est quoi la réponse
Auguste vilel est né le 8 juillet 1858 à
Saint-Denis son père Paulin propriétaire
terrien l'envoi en France suivre des
études secondaires catholiques en 1880
après la fermeture des écoles
chrétiennes il se retrouve chez sa tante
à Paris là il fréquente les milieux
littéraires il rejoint les Parnassiens
comme le comte de Lille ou Léon Diaz et
rencontre même Victor Hugo sa passion
pour la poésie inquiète son père qui le
fait revenir à Bourbon il travaille
alors à ses côtés sur les propriétés et
à la Chambre d'Agriculture c'est là
qu'il se découvre une vocation pour la
grenouille
autodidacte il n'en devient pas moins
une sommité internationale il voyage
beaucoup s'exprimant en latin à
l'étranger il ramène des plantes d'un
peu partout des épineux des Indes pour
nourrir le bétail ou des crapauds pour
chasser les moustiques en 1894 il
devient conseiller technique de la
Chambre d'Agriculture
il lance la revue agricole puis il part
7 ans dans l'isleur fait le tour du
monde avant de revenir dans son île
natale son goût pour les lettres ne l'a
pas quitté en 1926 il publie un recueil
de poèmes rayon de miel il met en place
l'académie de la Réunion et le premier
syndicat d'initiative de Saint-Denis en
1936 en lui retire la direction de la
revue agricole on lui reproche d'avoir
utilisé des subventions à des fins
d'agrément alors qu'il s'agissait d'un
voyage d'études
déçu il quitte la Réunion il meurt à
Paris en 1943